blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman welcome to the david pakman show
i'm farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today
we've got a lot to cover so let's hop
right into it first and foremost i want
to start
with where i am located the state of
florida
as everybody knows right now the state
of florida is watching as
covid absolutely ravages this state
to complicate matters in just a couple
days
next week most school districts here in
the state of florida
resume children going back to school
virtually no mask mandates in place and
that
is thanks to an executive order signed
by our trump-loving republican governor
ron
desantis just a couple weeks ago
desantis
signed an executive order expressly
forbidding
school districts counties cities
from putting any kind of mask mandate in
place and he followed that up by the way
with a threat to strip federal funding
actually state funding excuse me from
any school
that implements a mask mandate
at the same time that this is happening
florida just two days ago had over
twenty
thousand new coveted cases the second
highest day on record for us
we have had over 40 000 deaths
in this state alone the last
week of july we had more than
10 000 children
test positive for covid19
our icus are filling up
with men women and children as well
and desantis is sending everybody back
to school
and expressly saying you cannot
implement policies to protect these
children that is what we are dealing
with
here in the state of florida
there's a little bit of hope though
right now we have several counties that
have decided
to fight back orange county which is the
big
area of orlando it's where the theme
parks are huge population
there they decided along with broward
county down in south florida another
huge
huge county that they were going to defy
desantis and they decided to go ahead
and put the mask mandates in place
for school children now this was
actually before
desantis signed his executive order but
after his threat
of do not uh you know put a mask mandate
in place
so then after he signs the order
threatens to strip the funding broward
said well okay hold up
we're going to rescind the mask mandate
we're not going to
do it now we're not going to go along
with it and then something amazing
happened
several other counties leon county which
is where tallahassee our capital is
they said we're going to do mass for
children at least for a couple weeks
alachua county said you know what we're
going to do the same thing
orange county of course was doing it
then after everybody else jumped in
broward county came back and said uh you
know what
we are going to put our mask mandates in
place to protect our children
as they go to school other school
districts
are currently actually today having
meetings
about whether or not to put mandates in
place to protect uh
i think it's usually about k through
eight children
by putting mask mandates in place
obviously
if they hit 12 years old they're
eligible for the vaccine
but that's of little comfort to parents
who have children
basically sixth grade or younger at this
point
so what's happening now is they're
essentially daring
the governor saying we're putting these
mandates in place we're going to protect
these kids
you've told us you're going to strip our
funding
what are you gonna do about it
basically playing a game of chicken with
this little wannabe florida dictator
and i love it i love it not just because
of the political stance that they're
taking trying to say
you cannot you know have ultimate
authority
over every single aspect of this state
there are certain things that as a
school board as a county
we can do to protect our residents
most importantly because the the legal
showdown
that if desantis chooses to enforce
any of his uh you know rules
this thing is going to go to court and
there
it's a mixed bag especially down here in
florida courts we have seen some
horrible decision come from some
ridiculously right-wing packed courts so
it's likely
they could side with governor desantis
it's also
just as likely that in the interest of
the public's health safety and welfare
they could say that no the counties are
exercising their authority to protect
their residents again because of the
makeup of the courts not just here but
on the appellate level as well
it's a mixed bag and we really can't
predict or even pretend
to know what kind of decision we would
actually get
from any of these courts but we can hope
and i think right now that's probably
the best we have
because here's what's happening the
public
is actually starting to in in small ways
turn
on ron desantis who as we all know is
essentially at this point the heir
apparent to donald trump's political
apparatus should donald trump not run
for president again in 2024
desantis has been rising in those
nationwide republican polls
but over the past couple weeks the polls
down here in florida telling us a much
different story
as it stands right now and granted i'll
give you this
there's one poll where desantis is now
losing to democratic rival charlie crist
who actually used to be our republican
governor
now he says he's a democrat but anyway
he's beating
ron desantis by one point in the latest
poll
45 crist 44 desantis and the poll
of course has a 1.6 margin of error
and we're still 15 months out from the
actual election so the poll doesn't mean
a whole heck of a lot
but it is showing us
that at least some people here in the
state are paying attention
they're watching as we have days where
we literally have tens of
thousands of people coming down with
covid where we send
thousands more to the hospital
because of this children are being
hospitalized at an alarming rate here in
the state of florida
and desantis would rather make this into
a political issue
than a public health issue earlier this
week
you know he got into a bit of a tiff i
guess you'd call it
with the white house because joe biden
called him out
said you know florida texas you know
either
do what you need to do or stay out of
our way so we can do what we need to do
to protect people
and desantis fired back at a press
conference said i'm going to stand in
the way all the way
that means putting our kids in danger
another story came out this week from
politico where they
talked to administrators school board
members and principals from schools
across florida
and a lot of them told the same story
you know as i mentioned school's
starting in uh just
three days at this point
some of them don't have the staff to do
it either because they've had to bury
too many of them
in recent months due to covid or because
they have suffered massive outbreaks
once teachers went back
you know teachers always have that week
of pre-planning
everybody got exposed so now you have
schools that are going to start
some of them having teachers in the
double digits
out on quarantine they don't have the
staff to run their schools
one said we're literally losing our
workforce that is the quote
literally losing our workforce
and desantis won't let us protect our
our teachers or our kids
i'm hoping he backs off this but
honestly i don't think he will
because for him this truly is a
political
statement has nothing to do with science
has
nothing to do with the safety of people
here in the state of florida
it's all politics and he is pandering
to the worst of the worst
and if he wants a bit of a lesson in how
that turns out
he needs to look over to the state of
arkansas
arkansas governor asa hutchinson
a republican came out this week
and admitted oops i shouldn't have
signed a
ban on mask mandates in my state
now that coveted numbers are going
through the roof again
i messed up is the message that we got
from
arkansas republican governor asa
hutchinson
this week here's a couple quotes i want
to read here this is what hutchinson
said
well i signed it at the time because our
cases
were at a very low point i i knew it'd
be overridden by the legislature if i
didn't sign it i already eliminated our
statewide mass
mandate i signed it for those reasons
that our cases were at a low point
everything has changed now
and yes in hindsight i i wish that had
not become
law so
yeah i did it oops
wish i hadn't but you know it's not like
i'm in a position of
power to do anything about it you are
though
okay and hey it's great that you've come
around and realized you messed up
too little possibly too late at this
point he is of course
now asking the legislature to at least
overturn the part of the law that
doesn't allow school districts
to decide whether to put mass mandates
in place so at the very least asa
hutchinson is
is out there begging the
republican-controlled legislature
can you guys at least make it to where
school districts get to make their own
decisions about protecting the kids
but folks this is what happens this is
why you can't have these reactionaries
as leaders they give in
to the worst of their constituents
the people who say that masks are
tyranny or that masks are somehow
oppression they're neither by the way
but they signed this law to gain
political points
both over in arkansas over here in
florida
because they think it's going to gain
them some political points
and then boom everything blows up
and their hands are essentially tied at
this point now
over here in florida ron desantis could
could come out and make the same kind of
statements that asa hutchinson has
because at least hutchinson had the good
sense to be like
whoa folks i messed up so bad
of course he wasn't that extreme with it
but desantis is over here
watching again as we just had a day
where 20 000 people
got diagnosed with covid i have family
members in the hospital right now down
in south florida
in the icu so this
is a personal thing for me it is a
political thing for me it does hit close
to home for me
and desantis is doubling down saying
yeah biden i'm going to stand in your
way
i am not going to comply i am not going
to listen to the cdc
i am not going to let anyone other than
me
decide what's best for the millions and
millions of residents here in the state
of florida
that oh by the way are dropping dead
because of my idiotic decisions
desantis's poll numbers have also taken
a massive hit
because of this as i mentioned the one
poll obviously he's
trailing his democratic rival that one
will change
hopefully for the better but his
approval rating has now fallen to 43
as of this morning now
43 percent still not horrible
but when you consider the support that
this guy had he has dropped by double
digits
in just the last month
that's how extreme this is that's how
extreme he
is and the residents are waking up to it
and they're waking up to it
every time another relative goes into
the hospital
they're waking up to it every time they
have to put another family member in the
ground
it's terrifying and it's horrible that
this is what it's taking some people to
finally wake up and realize that
sometimes you have to put the science
over the politics
but people are starting to see exactly
how dangerous desantis's policies
truly are he's not going to pull an asa
hutchinson
he's not going to come out and say i
screwed up i regret this
he's going to continue to double down
because he thinks
it's going to help him politically even
though the numbers show
it's doing the exact opposite i'm fern
cousin sitting here for
david pakman today we'll be right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from
ring of fire sitting in for david pakman
today you can follow me on twitter by
the way
at farron balanced you can also find me
on facebook and instagram
at fair and balanced i'm on youtube
youtube.com
theringofire and youtube.com
farron balanced now we've got a bit of
an issue here right
if you've been paying attention to the
news this week you have no doubt seen a
little bit of speculation
about marjorie taylor greene possibly
running for president and the reason
these stories have been popping up
throughout the week
is because it was recently announced
that marjorie taylor green on august
19th i believe
it is is about to make a trip to the
iowa state
fair and for those of you who may not
know the significance of the iowa state
fair you know how every primary season
we get the photographs of
candidates and they're chowing down on
the big old corn dogs and
meeting with people yeah that's usually
from the iowa state fair this
is essentially the launching ground of
many
presidential campaigns they go to iowa
at this state fair which is massive to
test the waters
to gauge the response of the individuals
in attendance
and marjorie taylor green is going to go
there
so it has prompted this speculation as
to oh my god is she actually thinking of
running for president
this person who's been in office for
eight months now already been stripped
of her committee assignments
and now she might be running for
president and to that i say
hold your horses folks now she may be
running for president i'll get to that
in a minute
but let's not jump to those extreme
conclusions just yet
okay we know that for the last several
months marjorie taylor green has been
touring the united states
with matt gates they've been going out
spewing election lies attacking
democrats attacking republicans
attacking the deep state attacking quite
possibly anybody
that they think is going to benefit them
politically by attacking
we also know that in the recent weeks
they've kind of struggled to find venues
right
got kicked out of three different places
over in california recently had to
hold their little rally on a sidewalk
with just a handful of people in
attendance
so to me the most likely
explanation as to why marjorie taylor
greene would be heading to the iowa
state fair
is because it is essentially a captive
audience
and she is incredibly uh uh
less likely to be kicked out of it
so why not right why not go there to
this thing that
everybody focuses on especially in the
world of politics
why not go there and do your spiel in
front of these individuals
why not go out there and talk to them it
doesn't have to be a presidential run
it could just be something as simple as
oh boy i have more people i can do my
little spiel to
i i feel like that's probably the most
likely explanation it is the simplest
explanation
she struggled to find an audience so
this would be it
but let's look at the extreme side okay
let's assume for a second
marjorie taylor green is actually as
they call it testing the waters for a
presidential run
bring it on like i am here
all day for that marjorie taylor green
won her election in georgia last year
running unopposed
getting 74 of the vote
okay she couldn't even crack a solid
three quarters of the vote
when nobody was running against her
from this tiny little georgia district
a deep red solid republican district and
she couldn't even get 75
yikes not to mention the fact that she
has made a spectacle
of herself all across the country at
this point
she's done it throughout all of her
media appearances
all of her horrific tweets her
anti-semitic tweets
so if she wants to run for president go
for it
i seriously doubt you have any chance
whatsoever of being successful with it
i do not believe for a second that she
could end up being you know the kind of
dark horse person like donald trump
became
you know going out and basically telling
the people what they wanted
to hear to the point where they somehow
decided to vote for him i don't think
she has that potential
because she absolutely does not have
that kind of charisma that
odd charm that kind of sucks people in
she's just a train wreck
and i don't think she she would have any
chance whatsoever
all she would do in a presidential
primary
is just drag down the overall image of
the republican party so like i said
i'm here all day for it i hope
she is going to iowa to test the waters
for a presidential run
but i also truly don't believe that
that's what she's actually doing
and speaking of elections let's take a
look at what's happening in arizona
right
there have been all kinds of revelations
from
the state of arizona this week with the
ongoing ballot audit
that began in april
now in its fifth month everything is a
total secret
but earlier this week actually on monday
a magistrate judge in arizona said hey
republicans um actually karen fann
arizona republican senate president
you have to turn over all of the
documents
all of the communications that you have
about this ongoing ballot audit to the
groups who have sued
one of them being the media outlet
arizona republic
they have a right to have this
information
and now you have senate republicans
desperately
fighting and openly defying this court
order
to turn over their communications about
the ballot
audit here's what they're looking for
quote any and all records with a
substantial nexus to the audit
are public records the judge says this
includes
all communications related to planning
the audit policies and procedures of the
audit
and all records disclosing who is paying
for the audit and how much is being
spent
that seems pretty innocuous to me right
i mean we're not talking about turning
over the government's files on area 51
folks we're talking about hey
how is this being paid for and how did
y'all come up with the plan and what's
going on with it
that's it that's literally what these
groups are wanting to find
out and the judge says this stuff should
be public record it's supposed to be
public record
you got to release it and fan says no
i'm not going to do it
this is private this i guess is personal
this entire audit from the start as i'm
sure everyone watching this understands
this has been a farce it is absolute
political theater you have had
republicans from other states come in
tour the facility where they were
initially doing the ballot audit so they
could take the blueprints essentially
back to their own states
we also know that cyber ninjas the group
conducting the audit
uh basically broke the voting machines
now costing the the voters in arizona
three million dollars
because oops cyber ninjas accidentally
got a bunch of
malware installed in the voting machines
i'm sorry this is this is a terrible
terrible threat to our democracy
but it's also kind of hilarious at how
incompetent these individuals are
and now of course cyber ninjas wants to
get their hands on the routers
as if that's really going to tell them
much of anything um
cyber security experts agree that the
routers really are going to be
you know you're not going to get
anything on that you would have had to
have done it
at the time you know after the fact
you're you're not going to have any data
stored there most likely so
if you wanted that you should have done
it as things were happening so you could
have done the captures
which didn't happen so there's that
then of course this is all by the way
in the span of just two weeks a lot of
it happening this week
so you've got the republicans fighting
to keep everything secret they don't
want anybody to know what's happening
and gee
i wonder why that is and then you also
have
republicans subpoenaed both dominion
voting systems
and maricopa county officials
wanting even more information to hand
over to cyber ninjas and the maricopa
county folks said listen
the stuff you're asking us for we can't
turn it over
one because we don't even have it it's
not our stuff you're asking for
something that other
other uh state entities have so we can't
even do it
but two if we did have it we still
wouldn't do it
because what you're asking for includes
social security numbers
of our voters you know all of this
vital private information that if leaked
could absolutely result in a living
nightmare for these individuals so
yeah we don't have it so we can't give
it to you but if we did have it we
wouldn't give it to you we're not
complying with this subpoena we've
complied with everything else
you have everything you need from us go
away at this point is basically what
they're saying and dominion you know
came back with similar things
we've given you everything dominion says
anything else you ask for at this point
is ridiculous just like by the way this
entire ballot
audit is folks i have no doubt
and i have said this plenty of times you
know over on my youtube channel at fair
and balanced and at ring of fire
if they had found anything at all
anything
a single instance of fraud they would be
coming out holding press conference
saying ladies and gentlemen the
investigation is ongoing
but i want to highlight this this case
of fraud here that we found that had
gone unnoticed this is why the ballot
alderman
they haven't done that because they have
nothing to do that for
you also by the way a member of the
senate's appointed audit team
the leader of it came out and said oh we
found
74 000 ballots
mail out ballots that we have no record
of sending out
and then reporters actually looked at
the record and immediately said actually
there is a record of all of these going
out you're straight up lying to us now
so they're openly lying they're hiding
the information
and there's no signs of this thing going
away anytime soon it's been going on for
five
months and apparently it is just
going to keep on rolling
and while we're on the subject of
election fraud another quick thing i
want to hit on real quick here
this week it was revealed
that a doj official by the name of
jeffrey clark who i believe was in the
uh
was he in the civil rights division um
on december 28th he drafted a memo
that he was going to send to then acting
attorney general jeffrey rosen and then
acting
deputy attorney general uh ken donahue
and the letter said we're going to tell
the state officials in georgia
that their election was riddled with
irregularities
and therefore they need to hold a
special session of congress
so that they can not certify the results
of the election
and figure out how to move forward with
this so-called fraudulent election
jeffrey clark had the memo ready he sent
it to rosen and donahue and said
i've got this ready for all three of us
to sign here
and it's worth noting obviously that
clark is you know an avid trump loyalist
there in the doj
and luckily both rosen and donahue
looked at this memo and they said no
no we're not doing this this isn't true
what you're saying here is a lie the doj
already looked at georgia by the way
and we couldn't find any irregularities
we didn't see anything that raised any
red flags
we're not going to sign your stupid
little memo
and the reason i wanted to make sure i
hit on this story today folks is because
it does show that
even if a coup doesn't work even if it
never gets off the ground
isn't it still a [ __ ] nonetheless when
you had
members of the department of justice
and not just clark there were other
folks in this too
they were actively trying to overturn a
state's election results
just to appease donald trump because
this wouldn't have even changed the
results of the 2020 election
folks wouldn't have changed it
those electoral votes from georgia did
not put biden over the top
and thank goodness rosen and donohue had
enough sense
to say nope listen we're not going to
destroy democracy for you today
we got to take another break i'm fair
and cousins in for david pakman this is
the david pakman show
we'll be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular
show with no commercials you also get
access to our entire
archive of every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount
join pacman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show i am fair and cousins
from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today
the dixie fire ravaging out there
in the state of california this week
essentially swallowed up an entire town
the town of greenville
it was an old mining town has been
around for ages small population
estimated to be about 1200 and that fire
absolutely incinerated and destroyed
the downtown of this area
the dixie fire and of course many homes
and all of that the town is destroyed
much like paradise was
several years ago with that wildfire and
now we have another town
that is on the verge of not even
existing
because of this fire dixie fire has been
raging for three weeks now
and it is just one of what are one of my
numbers here
one of 97 wildfires
currently in the united states across 13
different states
we have 97 wildfires right now ravaging
the united states
20 000 active firefighters out there
trying to put out the flames
this is climate change let's be honest
the heat dome that we saw over the
pacific northwest
earlier this summer that's climate
change
we have such extreme temperatures over
on the west coast the northern west
coast
that we've literally had billions of sea
creatures
that have died because of the extreme
change in the water temperature
and to make matters worse with the dixie
fire and other fires
we're having another weather event you
know
strong gusting winds you know 30 40
miles an hour
that is making it difficult for
firefighters to be able to get there
and of course it's making it easier for
the fire to spread
and based on the reporting that i've
seen it does appear
that this fire much like the one that
destroyed the town of paradise
um was possibly started by faulty
equipment from california energy company
p g and e
this one they're saying they're they
believe there was a branch
laying on a piece of equipment that
could have sparked
and then caused the fire um obviously
it's it's a little too soon to uh
you know make bold accusations as to you
know pg e was definitely at fault for
this
first we got to work on getting the
flames out we've got to conduct the
investigations we've got to figure out
what exactly is happening here
um so that's what's being reported again
can't necessarily make one claim one way
or another
but what we do have to acknowledge the
claim we can make
is that extreme events like this
all of these fires not just the dixie
fire
this is what climate change looks like
we have watched all through 2021 to be
honest with you
as climate change isn't knocking at our
door
it's bursting through that door and
saying
i am here
winter storm yuri in texas that was
climate change saying
here i am look at me
the heat dome here i am the fires
that of course result from the droughts
and the extreme heat
i am here is what climate change is
telling us
now we have an administration now
that understands this we just went four
years with an administration
that at one point had said that climate
change was a hoax by the chinese
and the trump administration actively
worked to roll
back environmental protections
emission reductions fuel efficiency
all for no other reason than he wanted
to undo parts of president obama's
environmental legacy
and republicans cheered this stuff on
they were happy about it
oh boy he's repealing the the mat
standard
so there's going to be more mercury in
our
air they were happy about these things
but climate change is here i know
i know i know i know the study from 2018
saying we got 12 years until the worst
effects of climate change might not just
hit us but might also become the norm
well guess what that was three years ago
that that came out and we essentially
had three years
at that point and two years prior to
that of backpedaling on the issue of
climate change
more emissions even though we had the
pandemic last year global emissions
actually still increased
we're not getting better yet
but we can there is still time
and with an administration that
understands the dangers of this
have they gone as far as i want them to
on the issue of climate change
absolutely not like
really not even close to what needs to
happen
but at least we're finally moving in the
right direction
and you can't be upset about that we can
be frustrated that we're not doing
everything that needs to be done yet
and that's why we keep pushing and
that's why we keep fighting
here's a little bit of silver lining
though democrats
in the senate led of course by bernie
sanders and elizabeth warren
are pushing a draft for the
reconciliation package
that would include 500 billion
dollars that would be collected from
fossil fuel companies
to pay for the admissions that they
spewed out from the years 2000
to 2019. now chuck
schumer for the record has stayed mum
on whether or not he is going to include
this 500 billion
fine essentially on fossil fuel
companies to pay for their
emissions but why not right
i mean heck one of the big issues we're
having
with this reconciliation bill is oh gee
it's it's very expensive how are we
going to cover the cost
well if it's three and a half trillion
we can pay for that half by putting this
provision
in there the fossil fuel companies
as has been widely reported have known
about the dangers of climate change
since at least the 1970s
i've actually gone through the documents
for some reporting
back when i was with desmog blog and
actually they do have documents
going all the way back to the 1950s
where they talk about the fact that we
believe that the burning
that we're doing of these fuels could
possibly be changing the actual
atmosphere
it's remarkable and i know everybody
says that they've known since the 1970s
but if you go through those documents
their internal documents
they've actually been concerned about
this since the 50s it was just really
confirmed for them
in the 70s so either way
they have known about the dangers of
fossil fuel burning they have known what
it does to this planet
and yes it is time for them to pay us
back
because these emissions that go out
there these extreme weather events that
we see as a result of climate change
they cost money they cost lives
and yet instead of making these
industries pay for it we're
subsidizing them to the tune of i think
direct cash subsidies is at 14 billion a
year at this point
this is nuts it's time for them to pay
up
and this draft that is not yet in the
reconciliation bill but they want to get
it in the reconciliation bill
but this draft would absolutely
be a great start to get us where we need
to be on this issue
and speaking of democrats pushing much
needed legislation
this week several uh democratic uh
members in the house of representatives
and in the senate
have pro proposed excuse me legislation
called the right to vote act
and what the right to vote act which
let's
give credit here you got representative
mondaire jones
uh senators john office and alex padilla
they introduced this piece of
legislation on wednesday what it would
do
is would ensure that courts respect the
right to vote
as the fundamental right that it is it
is the first congressional guarantee of
the right to vote in federal elections
it also solves the problem that we are
seeing in certain states of election
subversion
the bill would affirm americans right to
vote by declaring election laws or rules
that pose a severe or discriminatory
burden
to be illegitimate unless the
jurisdiction in question can prove
that it that its proposed law or rule
furthers a governmental interest
and is the least restrictive means of
doing so
so once again we have democrats
in the house and in the senate
that are saying we have to do something
to protect the right to vote for
americans
you know what is it close to 200 pieces
of legislation being worked on across
the country
we all know texas right now is trying to
be the latest to pass a massively
restrictive voting bill
george has already done it florida's
already done it other states are trying
to get it done as well
federal legislation could circumvent
this federal legislation
could render all of these other pieces
dead
here's the problem
in some of the areas where this
legislation has passed
and i'm not saying this would be
effective i'm just saying this is a
possibility
you have states that have already passed
these restrictive voting bills
if the federal government were to come
out
with federal legislation basically
undoing these state bills
the states would actually have a pretty
decent 10th amendment case to bring
against the government
you know you didn't have a law in place
so we put our own in place and so ours
existed prior to yours it may not be the
strongest legal argument but i guarantee
you
we would see it coming out of these
states you know the state's rights
groups
would be fighting this tooth and nail
doesn't mean it would be successful it
just means if something like
the right to vote act did end up passing
it would still have a long journey
through the u.s
courts before finally becoming law of
the land to be
honest or possibly even being struck
down by the united states supreme court
that as we all know has a huge
conservative slant right now
but all of that is future talk and
there's a time for future talk
and there's a time to just acknowledge
that yes
democrats are actually working
to do good things for the united states
and sometimes you just got to take a win
when you can get a win
and sometimes that win is just the draft
legislation
whether it's the right to vote act
whether it's that you know
500 billion dollar fine
that sanders and warren want to levy
against fossil fuel companies
a win is a win corey bush
with her protest essentially to extend
the eviction moratorium
that worked we may only get an
extra 60 days of an eviction moratorium
but direct
action produced a result and democrats
are not
sitting idly by some of them
because we all know some of them are but
some of them are not
sitting idly by in washington dc
watching as republicans strip voting
rights away from
constituents because that's the only way
they can stay in power
they've admitted that too many times
over just the past year
for us to not acknowledge that that is
why this is happening
republicans know that the public changes
demographics shift people's viewpoints
change look at polling on
issues stripped away from politicians or
political parties
and on the issues america is actually
very progressive
that only changes when you attach a
political ideology or a specific
politician to the policy by the way
something to to keep in mind when you
see these numbers americans support
these things republicans support these
things
they support the infrastructure bill
they support action to
reigning climate change they support
raising taxes on corporations
the wind is at your back democrats i
want to see
more of this not just because i want you
to prove that you can fight
but because i actually have a vested
interest as an american
in watching everybody's lives get better
i'm faring cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show welcome back to the
david pakman show i am fair and cousins
sitting in for david pakman today and
don't forget
you can follow me on twitter in fact on
all social media
at farren balanced you can also get me
on youtube.com
fair and balanced and the big youtube
channel
youtube.com slash the ring
of fire well folks we've done a good job
today so far
of not talking about donald trump
so let's talk about donald trump right
now because there has been some
some trump developments this week the
first thing i want to talk about here
there was a piece this week from a good
friend of mine at salon.com
writer by the name of chauncey devega a
piece titled
are trump's followers being conned no
they gave him 100 million because they
love him
if you have a chance i encourage
everybody go read this piece because i
love it
see for a long time many many years
actually
i have been saying that trump is conning
his supporters
so when i saw this piece i almost felt
like oh oh no i hope i'm not mentioned
in it because i've had mentioned they'd
be
were being conned even earlier this week
when it was reported that donald trump
had a hundred million dollars
100 million dollars that he is
definitely not using to help his good
friend rudy giuliani but that's a story
for a different day that david actually
covered earlier this week
either way trump's got 100 million
dollars he's raising it from all over
the country people just
sending him money money money
he's spending it at his own properties
to a degree hundreds of thousands of
dollars have been spent on his own
properties
which he has a hundred percent interest
in some of the properties where it's
been spent so most of it goes right back
into his own pocket
so my logical conclusion is yes these
individuals are being conned
because some of this money a good chunk
of it was raised under the guise of
we're going to use this the trump pacs
were going to use this to pay for
ballot audits to pay for election
challenges
and they spent a whopping zero dollars
on it
so they gave trump money thinking it was
going to one thing and then it didn't go
to that
and i you know would come to the
conclusion logically
these people are being conned
but chauncey de vega actually makes a
much better point
than i was able to make and he says
it's not that they're being conned sure
they might be being
conned but they also don't care they
would still give the money to him
regardless and there's a great
explanation as to why
see we found out late last year
that the trump campaign was essentially
and the rnc did it i think a little bit
too
but anyway they were essentially
scamming their supporters and
auto enrolling them in these monthly
donations
so somebody thought they're giving a
one-time donation they didn't read the
fine print they didn't go through all
the
you know hurdles to turn off the
recurring payment
and so they just kept month after month
after month some people lost you know
tons and tons of money for this
and even after they turned it off though
some of them are still giving money to
donald trump
they said oh yeah it was horrible we got
swindled here
yeah we're still gonna give him money
and that's just one example that
you know kind of proves the point that
they don't care that they're being
conned
and that's a point that the vega really
makes very well in this piece is that
even if the money doesn't go where they
think it's going to go
even if they're told one thing and a
completely opposite thing
happens they still like him
they still want him to be the president
they still support him
they are still going to give him
that money now i had actually mentioned
in a segment on my channel fair balance
earlier this week
that i've run out of sympathy for these
people i have no more empathy
if they go bankrupt giving money to
donald trump
sure i don't want it to happen but at
this point they've had enough
warnings that if it happens it happens
because it's worse than being conned
and that's kind of the point that the
vega makes in the piece you know that
that's that's the big
conclusion here is that it's worse than
a con
it's a cult that's what it is it doesn't
matter what he does to some of these
people
again i'm not saying all republicans are
in the cult but
you do have this die-hard sect of trump
supporters
that it is really difficult to describe
them as anything else
because it doesn't matter what he says
it doesn't matter what he does
it doesn't matter if he lies to their
face about it
heck we got reports that he likely
didn't donate
the last couple uh uh months of his
salary like he promised to always do
and his kids would always boast about on
social media
we also know that gdp growth under
donald trump this
another story came out this week was the
lowest it's ever been since the great
depression
no president had worse gdp growth than
donald trump george w
bush came close his was 1.8 percent over
eight years
trump's was 1.6 percent over four years
so economically speaking
the guy was really really bad but the
supporters don't care
they're still clamoring for him they
still want more from him they still
want him to be president again probably
holding out hope that what is this
a week from august 13th at this point oh
my god
you know if lindell's original
correction was correct
or prediction was correct excuse me we'd
be a week away from trump coming back
and these people would love it
they don't care about the lies they
don't care about the vulgar behavior
they don't care about how he mocked a
disabled reporter way back in the day
they don't care about any of it
and they don't care what he uses their
money for
they just want to keep giving it to him
and at this point
those individuals it's likely that they
can't be pulled out of this certainly
not by somebody like me
you know you would need somebody who
actually understands
that kind of cult mentality and how to
actually deprogram people
which yes there are experts in that and
those are the ones
who really would have to work on these
individuals but until then
they're going to keep giving until they
can't give any more
they know they're being conned they just
stopped caring
and another person trump appointee
out there conning more people this week
an inspector general
appointed by donald trump came out this
week
saying that they did a thorough
investigation and it turns out that the
ppe problems that america had
in the early days of the pandemic which
seems like centuries ago at this point
those ppe issues it wasn't the fault of
the administration
or the coronavirus task force that he
had put together no
siree it was fema it was all
totally fema homeland security inspector
general joseph kufari
came out and said this the magnitude of
the global event exposed weaknesses in
fema's resource request system and
allocation processes
specifically web eoc the system fema
used to
process ppe and ventilator resource
requests
contained unreliable data to inform
allocation decisions
and ensure requests were accurately
adjudicated
in addition although fema developed a
process to allocate the limited supply
of ventilators it did not
have a similar process for ppe there it
is folks case closed according to mr
kufari
fema fema's to blame for how horrible
things were in the early days of the
pandemic
what i love about this is that this is
complete history erasure
we remember how things worked at that
time
you had jared kushner in charge of
ppe and that didn't work out so well
you had ppe that was being taken from
some hospitals
put over in these other places where
trump and his little coronavirus task
force
would then decide how to allocate it
they were taking things from
fema not letting fema do what they were
supposed to we all know that
those reports were everywhere
this this is just mind-blowing and
sometimes
you get a story like this that just
shakes you to your core
because you know how false it is because
folks
we all lived through this i know i said
it feels like centuries ago
but i'm hoping the more i say these
things it jogs your memory and
everybody's like oh wait yeah
i do remember that this was crazy times
it was the wild wild west of ppe with
our own government
acting as the bandits taking it from
these places
and reallocating it based on where they
felt
it needed to go for example in the early
days of the pandemic
new york was getting hit harder than
anybody florida was actually doing
pretty well
and this was you know march april 2020
folks
but still they were sending all this ppe
all these ventilators down to the state
of florida
and we had more than we could ever need
down here
meanwhile new york was having to put
people in hospital beds
in parking garages without ventilators
because they just had nothing
and they were getting nothing and the
difference is obviously new york had a
democratic governor
florida had a trump-loving republican
governor it's
really not that hard to put the pieces
together and yet here you have this
report from kufari coming out and saying
nope coronavirus task force they did
everything right
fema screwed up because their computer
systems were stupid
now i'm not trying to absolve fema of
any you know
any problems that they had during the
painting because sure they had plenty
everybody had plenty we weren't prepared
for this
we had been cutting pandemic funding we
had been cutting preparedness
the trump administration completely
ignored
a response plan that the obama
administration had put in place we had
some protocols
certainly not even enough but we didn't
even follow those
so it is what it is coveted ran rampant
still is rampant is mutating
at an alarming rate at this point we're
now getting reports out this week
that the lambda variant and i think
whichever one is after that
the other variant they mentioned they
think those might actually be vaccine
resistant
and if that is the case we're back to
square one folks
we would be back to lockdowns we would
be back to stay at home orders mask
mandates
all of that from the beginning because
our vaccines
would be useless against new variants
it is what it is you know we we've we've
elected
crazily and competent people
and we're reaping the uh repercussions
of that
and it's terrifying and yes it's unfair
to the people who didn't vote for all of
these incompetent buffoons but
nevertheless
every election can have nationwide
consequences
you know you may not live in florida you
may not have had the chance to vote
against ron desantis
like i did but his idiotic decisions
letting covid run rampant here
are still going to affect you where you
are because the more we have it here
the more it mutates the more it travels
same thing with abbott over in texas
same thing with hutchinson and arkansas
and ivy in alabama and all of these
other southern states where it's blowing
up
it's going to make it back to the blue
states it's going to make it to the west
coast it's going to make it to the
you know midwest
all of these decisions from all of these
politicians big and small
local and national they all affect
each and every one of us
fema screwed up in the beginning the
white house coronavirus task force
screwed up even worse than that
trump screwed up governor screwed up
democratic and republic
uh republican governors hid covet data
cuomo and desantis i'm looking at you
both
and and we're still stuck in it and as i
mentioned we may be back to square one
really soon but hey
i appreciate you tuning in today and i
appreciate david pakman
and everybody else at the david pakman
show for letting me fill in
again i am fair and cousins you can get
me on twitter
instagram facebook at fair and balanced
youtube.com
the ring of fire and my personal youtube
youtube.com slash
fahren balanced thanks for watching and
stay tuned for today's bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman